[Music]
in the heart of beirut is a reminder of
this country's bloody sectarian history
a 1960s theater never finished riddled
instead with the bullet holes from
lebanon's civil war of the 70s
40 years on their queueing to get in
this symbol of lebanon's past
is the venue now for young students to
try and control their future
the speaker is a former government
minister turned protester
if the revolution is successful he hopes
then political leadership lies with them
who amongst you can carry this protest
he asked without blood being spilt
the secular non-sectarian unity of this
nationwide movement has surprised
everyone but they know it's fragile
and not far from the theater that was
clear
this isn't a fight between protesters
and police it's between protesters and
other protesters
supporters of hezbollah clashing with
demonstrators in central beirut
members of the islamist group who have
both ministers in government
and the country's most powerful militia
confronted protesters they
claimed were insulting their leader it
wasn't prolonged the police separated
the two groups
but it is a hint of how precarious this
revolution as they call it
could be when the hezbollah leader
hassan nasrallah spoke
not the secular protesters potentially
driving the first
wedge into the movement and in the south
of the city his supporters were out
quickly with the hezbollah flag
not the national flag further to the
south down the mediterranean coast is
the city of sidon
here like everywhere they're out on the
streets among them university professor
dr
you have ismael potential to have a very
nice economics
at the heart of the movement he says is
a drive for a new
secular politics but the religious sects
currently in power
won't allow it keep religion outside the
government we have to have an
unreligious government
but the political people that have
religious group they all said no this
will not work
it will not work these people say it
will work
through the week the leaders of each
political faction have failed to
persuade their followers to back them
the people have stayed out and want them
out but with supporters of a movement as
powerful as hezbollah breaking rank with
the protesters
the dynamic has changed the first doubt
about whether the revolution really can
run the course
or if the sectarianism that has fueled
politics here
will again prevail mark stone sky news
in lebanon